[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels
real and raw political and social
commentary the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not liberty
you [ __ ] eating [ __ ] ah the smell of
freedom of speech this is the tony
michaels podcast and this is tony
michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] them
[Music]
good
tuesday morning is it taco tuesday
a lot of news
today
[Music]
some big stories that should be bigger
stories
and some little stories that
we just have to talk about
and there seems to be a certain family
a certain specific son
who went on fox news sean hannity last
night and seems very afraid very very
very afraid
and
[ __ ] dumb [ __ ] so we'll get into the
eric trump durham
why won't they prosecute hillary well
that that's that's because there is no
[ __ ] evidence you dummies
it's all the ruse it's all to keep you
all [ __ ] up in the head to think that
hillary clinton is somehow taking over
the world she wasn't
president she was not president she was
never a president i don't know if they
knew that like i think i think they
thought like you know how they think
like
trump is still a president joe biden's
like on some set in hollywood or some
stupid [ __ ] [ __ ] that q on [ __ ]
i think i think that maybe what they
thought during trump's presidency that
hillary clinton was actually president
trump was just on some apprentice set
somewhere
i don't know i can't figure this [ __ ]
out i can't figure this [ __ ] out how
people don't know that john durham is
full of [ __ ] [ __ ]
he's full of [ __ ] and it's clear he's
full of [ __ ] he's like yeah there's
there's this thing i want to accuse
someone of because the media says
something there's no evidence but
i want to accuse them in this official
court document get the [ __ ] out of here
with that [ __ ]
no one's buying your garbage
nobody
no one's are the only people that are
buying it are that that want to [ __ ]
eat the [ __ ] sandwich
and really honestly let them
let them make this year about hillary
clinton like no one gives a [ __ ]
about hillary clinton
everyone's saying good morning good
morning yoda good morning kaelin
kaelin's tired yoda says good [ __ ]
morning
uh david says good morning from the bay
area
ann is here
patty is here mj is here hey gang
patty how are you this morning
everyone's here this morning
they're ready they're ready to tear [ __ ]
up
we got a lot of we got a lot of news get
to we got i i think
i think we're gonna have
possibly we're gonna have a special
guest today um you guys know we have
these little poppins that we do
and uh we're gonna be talking about the
eric trump story eventually so maybe
maybe just maybe we'll have a special
guest gabe was supposed to
join us today but maybe it'll be uh
maybe it'll be someone else if you know
what i mean
now you guys have you guys been enjoying
the
the gabe costume show ups oh my god last
week let's see here he was twitter tech
support
he was uh a pastor of brian
uh let's see he showed up yesterday as
um carly sherk
the uh the correspondent for really news
now and this is getting this is getting
ridiculous
now i want i want to give you full
disclosure i i don't know what he's
going to do
or who he's going to show up at
sometimes he'll float like hey this is
who's going to show up
but the other day with tech support no
clue no idea i had no idea that he was
gonna show up
but it's fantastic we love to bring the
humor we love to bring the comedy we
love the clown these [ __ ] it is
so fun to clown them and i think it's
essential to clown them
uh you've seen what's happened in the um
in at the canadian border
uh speaking of clowns
and clowning people
and they're they're they're trying to
overthrow democracy under this
this guy's of anti-vaxx anti-mask
freedom [ __ ]
they're trying to use freedom to
overthrow democracies it's very clear
when you see an anti-vaxx rally now the
people there may be being duped to be
fair they may they may have been duped
in the ivermectin facebook group about
some of this stuff but ultimately the
people funding these things
the aim
of any anti-vaxx rally or anti-mask
rally at this point is pro covid
and if you're and at this point
it's beginning to have this stench
that they're just using this wedge to
tear down democracy now i've been saying
it for a long time i've been saying that
they're that they're trying to continue
the coveted chaos right and it's no more
clear than now what the fascist in this
country aim is is to create some kind of
chaos
and and
and basically
in simplest terms to so doubt an
american's mind that even democracies
around the world can't work this is
putin 101. this is russian [ __ ]
like this this is the last 20 years of
vladimir putin's plan
in his worldwide quest to kill democracy
and the republicans are using it play by
play by play
all the way down
to the fact that they can't even get
their message straight
think about this for a second
the very first year that joe biden
was president even though he wasn't
president
you know this [ __ ] two-way street
[ __ ]
joe biden was present for a full year
all's we heard about were supply chains
remember this for months
they they threw racist tropes
about ships being docked
at our ports from china and other
countries they use racist tropes
to blame supply chains they blame biden
for supply chains they've been
complaining about gas prices for a full
[ __ ] year
for a full year not understanding how
gas prices work this this is why they
love their sheep this is why they love
them uneducated
this is why they love them paying
attention to things like sexual anarchy
when it's a racist trope we had rachel
bitkoffer on yesterday she explained how
and we're gonna talk about it today
we're gonna talk about it today because
it's racist that's right when they say
sexual anarchy they're talking about
black people dancing
that's what they're talking about
that's what it is
doubt me daria
charlie kirk charlie kirk is not all
upset about a white girl
in a cowboy
cheerleader outfit
dancing around he's not upset about her
i'm not either i mean i'm not either but
he's not upset about her doing it
but mary j blige shows just this much
just this much of her thigh
sexually anarchy it's because she's
black
you guys remember uh
history on
reefer i don't know if you guys went
back and looked at like old propaganda
posters on reefer
the old tropes were that
black men are gonna smoke reefer and
rape your white women
it's the same [ __ ]
pedophile cabal [ __ ] that they place on
democrats george soros and all kinds of
weird ass [ __ ] [ __ ] that they've got
on facebook
and their stupid little right-wing
social media sites
and has infected their [ __ ] brains
their uneducated stupid-ass brains
what's happening and it's the same thing
that's happening in canada it's the same
[ __ ]
supply chain's bad
biden bad we need economy open economy
needs to be open to have freedom let me
in
don't shut down things
economy gets opening economy gets
running again people are going to
restaurants spending money stock markets
up
the gouging is up not inflation the
gouging is up
there are corporate profit partners
the money is flowing baby
the money is flowing
shut it all down that's what they say
shut it all down joe biden's gonna take
credit for the economy we can't have
that we gotta own the libtards so shut
down the economy destroy it destroy the
stock market lock the highways up think
about this i said this the other day
think about the message
i [ __ ] dare these [ __ ] dare
these [ __ ] to lock up highways
go ahead do that in this country lock up
all the interstates all the local
highways all the arteries in and out so
people can't go to work people can't go
do what the [ __ ] they want to do
try it
anytime in this country any time in this
country that we have something crazy
happen right
something crazy happens
and the airlines you can't get on a
[ __ ] plane all the planes are
canceled
you can't get on a plane fast enough
people start to freak out and they're
like nope can't do that sorry
no we can't do that we can't
we can't have people standing in line
like americans that's one [ __ ] they
were like leap liberty ah yeah that's
you know negotiable standing in line not
negotiable we will not [ __ ] stand in
line we will not wait [ __ ]
we can't wait more than five [ __ ]
seconds for something
just lock up the highways lock up the
highways republicans and encourage it
and go on go on tv yay lock up the
highways yay to own the
good [ __ ] luck
good luck with that message
good luck with that
with that [ __ ] political strategy to
make it to where people can't roam free
and about and go to work and go to the
grocery store do the [ __ ] they want to
do
oh my god
these [ __ ] idiots you can't convince
them of anything though
because you say one thing but
they'll find something else
donald trump and the trump organization
it appears that they're completely
[ __ ] i've been saying this for months
they're completely [ __ ] i retweeted my
video that the trump organization is
going down like a fresh-cut tree
which they are it's obvious
everyone knows that they committed fraud
everyone knows that he [ __ ] set it
into a microphone
he was saying it into a microphone for
decades and decades but yes i cheat on
my taxes it's really dumb if you don't
cheat on your taxes if you pay taxes
that's really stupid
he said it over and over and over and
over and over again hero didn't [ __ ]
well he didn't write it in books
he had other people write it and believe
it he didn't write books
but here we are the accounting firm
the official accounting firm in the
trunk organization
which uh it appears
that they've changed their name they
have russian offices
it appears
that they have they have flipped
uh oh
the pancake
accounting firm for the trump
organization
my guess is is that the when the
prosecutors found that
oh
there's fraud there's fraud in these
accounting records
the accounting firm's like oh but no we
didn't have anything to do with that
we're not gonna have anything to do with
him
they're flipping they're flipping
because they want to relieve themselves
of any legal and financial
responsibility that they possibly can
it's very clear where the uh the civil
lawsuit in new york is headed now tisch
james the attorney general of new york
is heading up the civil investigation
and it seems as if
the pressure on the accounting group and
the accounting group doing what they
doing basically redacting
over 10 years of accounting records
saying at their [ __ ] they were all
[ __ ]
it appears that that is going to be part
of the civil investigation but also we
know because the attorney general of the
state of new york tisch james
isn't working in coordination because
she is the attorney general elected
there
is working in tandem with the
criminal investigation that has already
indicted alan weiserberg the cfo of
trump organization and trump
organization itself
we forget that we [ __ ] forget that
every single day trump's private
business that he ran for decades is is
under criminal indictment he's a
criminal
and the people who ran the organization
don jr eric ivanka
allen weisselberg they're [ __ ]
criminals they're under indictment yeah
i knew pre innocent until proven guilty
but there's a lot of aim here that i
believe that the one aim of tisch james
is to make sure no matter what happens
with the criminal investigation that she
[ __ ] cuts
the trump organization off at the
knees to make sure that their money
laundering machine it does not exist
their ability to appear rich because
that's the rub
they're [ __ ] broke they're [ __ ]
flat broke he's been [ __ ] broke for a
long time it's only to appear to be rich
and everyone's like oh he's got a
hundred million dollars and 200 million
dollars yeah but you know how much
[ __ ] money he owes
so good luck
to donald
j trump and the trump organization
when the federal prosecutors in the
southern district of new york
decide to step in
and have a a federal case
because i believe that's where this is
headed
there's going to be a lot of federal
cases against this son of a [ __ ]
believe you me
it's not going to be pretty
everyone keeps whining and complaining
about the attorney general of the united
states merrick garland
well merrick garland is not the one
doing these investigations
in new york it's tish james
it's the manhattan d.a that's will lead
to these cases it's it's
it's prosecutors in georgia for election
fraud
possibly in arizona
they can't stop criming and they're not
gonna stop
that's why it seems like these
investigations are endless and there's
no end in sight and we get no results
because they're still crying like right
now they're still crying they're still
doing it
right now as we speak right here live on
the radio show because we're live every
weekday noon eastern 11 central and
they're criming at that time right now
they're criming somewhere there's
someone who is trump our trump ally or
in the trump organization in the trump
camp who is criming as we
speak need not forget
we have a lot to go over in the [ __ ]
list today we have prince prince andrew
guilty ass [ __ ]
who came to a a uh a plea deal or a deal
a settlement to get out of court
with his accuser
um remington there's another court case
that is a settlement remington settles
with the sandy hook parents which is
like historic this is historic stuff
um the roots picnic we see mary j blige
you know oh they're so scared of her
thighs
oh mary had her thighs out during the
super bowl halftime show the world's
gonna come to an end everyone's going to
be running around having sex everywhere
sexual anarchy get the [ __ ] out of here
with that [ __ ]
tulsi gabbard is it it appears to be
russian
uh john durham [ __ ] that guy
uh zero hedge there's something about
that uh
trudeau in canada adam schiff
eric trump and even dr fauci is trending
even dr bauchy is trending so let's get
to the shitless roundup let's start the
countdown
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome welcome back to
the [ __ ] list roundup where we round up
all the tweety tweets and the trendy
trends of the day
it's that time again it's that time of
the show um here soon we may have a
special guest that pops in on us we may
have to interrupt this [ __ ] list roundup
but we will try to get to as much [ __ ]
list as we can
until that time so let's go to the uh
let's see i can't even get my mouse to
work right okay let's go to the timeline
here
um here's uh
the accounting firm let's make this
bigger so we can see we all want to see
um how many days would hillary clinton's
accounting firm cut ty's trend at number
one
the story is breaking news donald and
this is new york times breaking news
donald trump's accounting firm cuts ties
with his company and redacted
retract excuse me retracted financial
statements
central to two investigation court
papers show mizar's mazars i don't know
how you say it [ __ ] them
can you imagine if hillary clinton there
was a [ __ ] new york times article
it'd be on the front [ __ ] page and
it's a hillary crooked
hillary's accounting firm it's all we
hear about is accounting firm accounting
firm hillary's accounting
emails emails
no one even knows this story exists go
ask your [ __ ] go ask the people at
your school
go ask the people at your church at your
work get up right now right now if
you're at work i know you're listening
at work you got me in your
ear bones
making sure no one can hear me
go get up go walk over to another desk
and say hey did you hear about this
[ __ ] accounting firm for the trump
organization who is under criminal
indictment
the trump organization is under criminal
indictment they're being charged with
fraud and crimes in the state of new
york
and their accounting firm
which helped them commit these crimes
apparently has retracted financial
statements
uh oh and they're cutting ties not only
did they retract these financial
statements they said go [ __ ] yourself we
are not your accountants anymore
go get [ __ ] bent kick rocks [ __ ]
because the trump organization is under
criminal indictment
and their their accounting firm walks
away can't even [ __ ] can't even
fathom if there was an obama
organization right that he ran for three
decades he claimed was all kinds of
money all kinds of real estate
oh it was fabulous the most fantastic
the most fantastic organization in the
world
it's under cr he was under criminal
indictment barack obama's organization
the obama organization
would be under criminal indictment can
you [ __ ] even imagine their hair
would be on fire this would be trending
at number one
they they would forget about dr fauci
even that's how [ __ ] big that would
be like they would even forget who the
[ __ ] he was
and that's almost impossible at this
point because they're [ __ ] completely
obsessed with dr fauci
they would absolutely love this but here
we are donald trump
is in that position a actual president
of the united states
who wouldn't divest in the business that
is under criminal indictment are you
listening to what i'm saying
this is how we go after these
[ __ ] this is the messaging that
we send do you know anyone who gets
endorsed by this [ __ ] isn't
being endorsed by the cheeto dust
mobster the guy whose accounting firm
won't have anything to do with him
think about that all these people out
there seeking his endorsement
cheering him on in the state legislator
races in these in these congressional
races the united for the united states
house of representatives these senate
races that are seeking his endorsement
getting on their [ __ ] knees
and and doing cheeto fellatio
this is what they're tied to this is
easy it's [ __ ] easy he's a [ __ ]
criminal his his organization is under
criminal indictment his cfo is under
criminal indictment and his their
accountant the entire accounting firm
not just like one of them all of them
anyone who ever worked on the records is
like no we don't want anything to do
with you not only that oh all those
documents that we prepared for you the
last [ __ ] decade we're going to
retract those because they're [ __ ]
they're all [ __ ] fake it's all
nonsense
this is who they want to be endorsed by
this is the endorsement that they're
seeking they're criminals
okay let's go back to the timeline
is tulsi russian like really she she
really does appear to be russian
like like hardcore
i mean i don't know if she's like
russian descent i'm just saying like
it really seems that way
um amy's got an opinion on on tulsi why
the [ __ ] is tulsi gabbard still claiming
to be a democrat
[Laughter]
uh tell us to grab gabbard
claims to be a lot of things we live in
in the upside down dan says
i think that's
highly accurate highly accurate
okay let's see here
oh did you guys know that um steve
schmidt is gonna be on i am politics
girl it was it's there i think i think i
think it's it's out
looks like it's out on the podcast steve
schmidt on i am politics girl i like
that i love that podcast
by the way uh lee mcgowan is fantastic
so you might want to go watch that
fred fred uh
brings up a good point here
uh that moderate and he's talking about
uh um jesus vicki hartzler moderate
vicki hartzer is not a [ __ ] moderate
she's a goddamn nazi
ma she's a moderate nazi
she's a moderate not vicki hartzler is a
nazi the moderate in missouri gop senate
race at josh hartland oh wait wait he
endorsed someone else
i was thinking of vicki hartzler oh
that's right she is a nazi she's not a
moderate
so [ __ ]
endorsed this weekend she just
put out an ad attacking transgender
athletes in indiana there are no
moderate republicans they're not they're
nazis
you're more likely to ride a t-rex to
work stop fantasizing about extinct
things
uh
i want to write a tea who wants to ride
a t-rex to work that'd be kind of fun
i'm just saying that that might be
that might be interesting to watch
i don't know
i don't know i mean you know if you're
gonna
say that
republicans are moderates they're
[ __ ] nazis and they're criminals
not only they're criminals they're not
the party of law and order they were the
party of law in order they would have
trashed trump long ago and they don't
and they won't
dan here has a thread the gop wants to
believe that biden controls gas prices
while simultaneously promoting free
market capitalism
they think you're stupid exactly you got
to read this thread by dan by the way go
take a look at it and i read it this
morning it's a great thread thank you
dan for the thread listen
this is all nonsense they say oh we
gotta open up the economy and then they
say shut it down because
the virus
is there's no more chaos you notice you
notice this variant ran throughout the
country killed
killed thousands of unvaccinated people
or getting back in a decent decent mode
here until the next [ __ ] variant
because we still have a large percentage
of the population unvaccinated
and and they're going to lose their
chaos they can't lose their covet chaos
because that's how they crush
democracies
is to cause chaos that's the whole point
their their their aim for chaos is not
for people not to get vaccinated or or
you know it seems pro coveted but the
reason why they're pro cove it is
because it's pro chaos and chaos
chaos can bang up democracies especially
when you throw a little fascism in the
in the chaos soup the [ __ ] out of here
with that [ __ ] chris says it's hard to
take durham seriously for two key
reasons
he has facial hair like a silent movie
villain more importantly he was
appointed by trump
exactly
i don't know
that the the first one is better than
the second one or the second one is
better than the first one i'm good
either way i'm good either way
um don says remember how the world
rejoiced when trump lost the election
yeah we were like yeah [ __ ] it's
about time
throw that fascist into trash flush him
down the [ __ ] toilet like he flushes
top secret documents imagine the
worldwide celebration if trump is
arrested
hashtag marknetpost thank you don
thank you don you are exactly right
you are exactly right it feels more and
more oh here's here's here was my
inspiration earlier for my comments
about the dallas
cheerleader and mary j blige don says to
some
one is blasphemous the other is
wholesome as apple pie
why
for those of you who can't see out there
who are just listening there's a picture
of mary j blige and her outfit from the
super bowl where you can see
her thighs and i'm not talking like the
whole guy i'm talking like a percentage
of it not a lot of it right
there's not a lot of thigh here and then
on the other side there is a dallas
cowboys cheerleader who has a lot of
thigh
a lot of mid-drift and a lot of boob
i'm i'm not saying either one of these
is wrong i'm cool with either one of
these i really am
i really am and
i like this kind of sexual anarchy if
that's what it is but why why are
conservatives so mad
that mary j blige shows this amount of
skin
and a white cheerleader for the dallas
cowboys shows that amount of skin
seems black and white
seems like in black and white i don't
know it seems like to me
could be
um i want to show this video here i say
i almost i almost never promote a good
ass kicking but this video here you to
see it's um kyle perkins
posted it it's a it's thai women beating
an american tourist for groping one of
them watch this uh watch this video here
he really does get his ass beat
women around the world are sick of this
[ __ ]
they're fed up with this kind of [ __ ]
these women here did not have any of
that
you [ __ ]
he looks like a charlie charlie kirk
type doesn't he you know one of these
alpha cuck types that's what he looks
like to me i'm just saying
all right thanks kyle for posting the
video i'm gonna retweet i'm gonna
retweet i i quote tweet you but we'll
retweet and we'll give thanks because we
read it we give credit and if we show it
you know it there you go that's it if we
show it you know it
okay let's see what else we got there
oh here's the eric trump video here's
the eric trump video let's watch the
eric trump video from last night um i
said where are the prosecutors working
hard to indict your dumb ass uh a very
emotional eric trump almost cries on
hannity let's listen to this [ __ ]
chucklehead
if hunter's last name was trump that's
all anybody would talk about
that's a big problem for this country
moving forward if we have a two-tiered
justice system sure
and sean where are the prosecutors right
now you know the same prosecutors
they'll go after my father every single
day for nothing right just because they
want to disqualify him because he's
clearly the frontrunner for 2024. right
where are those prosecuted hillary
rodham clinton is a new york resident
let me just kind of break that down for
you she lives in chappaqua new york and
guess where trump tower is located it's
located on fifth avenue
in new york where are these properties
all sorts
james in this whole thing is she just
going to ignore this because
hillary happens to be in her political
party
we don't get this fixed
what's funny is the john durham thing is
a federal case wait a second wait a
second wait a second here i think i
think we have a guest here might be
coming in uh to respond to this video
um
can can you hear me over there
yes i can
you can't
sir you is this eric trump are you eric
trump are you here to respond
yes i don't like the way that everyone
is talking about me and my father
leticia james is coming after my family
because it's unfair
it's unfair
you know you committed crimes it seems
what
what are you
no
[Music]
so so you're saying so you're saying
that your accounting firm dropping your
father's business um
does your does your dad know who you are
by the way
what does he know who you are eric this
is is your dad taking your phone calls
uh
have you heard from my dad no i i have
not heard from him i mean it's been a
couple weeks he was on the show a couple
weeks ago but
but um eric
i haven't heard from you
what what's wrong eric are you all right
why why are you so upset
are you upset because you think you're
going to go to prison are you going to
be someone's [ __ ]
eric eric get it together eric you're on
live you're on live this is not recorded
you're on live get it get it together
get it together here get it together
can you
we're live right now we're we're live
we're live
on youtube twitter and twitch uh the
tony michael's gone
on this [ __ ] liz
fear
what's not fair
why is leticia james coming after us
you committed crimes in the state of new
york it appears not only criminal but
civil as well i think they're gonna i
think they're gonna i think they're
gonna cut down who is it is that worse
yeah way worse
now
also also
also at the federal government figures
out what you did with fraud did you guys
commit fraud did you commit fraud
what
are you did you commit fraud your
business commit fraud
i don't you know what fraud means you
know what broadcast people coffee here
you what i just give people coffee you
get people at at the trump organization
you're just the coffee boy
they just say go make some copies and go
get some coffee
what are you making copies of do you
shred anything at the trump organization
is there a shredder there or do you just
use the toilet
are you talking about the confetti room
the confetti there's a confetti room
yeah sometimes they say we're gonna have
a party until then they're like go shred
this to this to make them
go shred it to make confetti and they're
gonna have what kind of parties do you
have there at the trump organization i
don't i don't know they just say oh
we're going to keep winning and so then
there's going so eric go go shred some
paper and then they make some confetti
and they said oh you can't i can't go to
the party store and they're like no you
got to shred it to make some confetti
and then i'm like
can i have some money and then like we
don't have any money
so you're out of money you don't have
any money left is that why you're making
copies do you have a copy machine where
you're printing money
or is or is just the whole trump
organization a a laundry mat
what about laundry do you know
wandering money it seems as if it seems
as if why would you put money in the
laundry well is that the same as when
you five like five dollars in the
laundry in your pants and then you're
like no no eric eric eric eric eric
eric
do do you consider yourself intelligent
what do you consider yourself
intelligent smart
intelligent means smart
yeah
you're you consider yourself smart
uh-huh what about your what about your
your older brother don do you think don
is intelligent intelligent again it
means smart
um
yeah
uh
am i under oath
no this
you're you're on a podcast you're not
under oath but you are live can i play
the fifth
the fifth
do you know what the fifth is
um it's the first amendment
not plus two second amendments
it that is
one plus two plus two is is five but
that that that's not exactly what the
fifth amendment said
to
rights to bear arms eric eric stay with
st stay with me stay with me or stay
with me here did you ever talk to ivanka
or don jr about laundering money
no
yes he didn't yeah no
no no you i don't there's not a specific
answer that i want you to give i want
you to tell me the truth that's all
anyone's looking for that's what okay
there was one time when they were like
hey eric uh we need you to go
throw some stuff in the laundry
i didn't know what they meant
right is this like a confetti room type
thing is this is there another room yeah
well i took it i took a bag i took bags
of stuff
and then i took it to these people yeah
and then they said
we've got it from here and i don't know
who
we got we got it from here so what did
they look like did they do they
did they appear to be russian
you're making me laugh and i don't know
if i should laugh or cry oh well well i
i would say i would say if um if
if this ends up the way that it seems
like it's gonna end up you're definitely
gonna be crying is that what you're
scared of are you scared to go to prison
are you scared to go to prison
have you ever considered that you might
go to prison
no
my dad said
yeah he said
he talked to you your dad actually
talked to you well like last year he
told me he said he said
don't worry about it
and i don't know what's
i don't know what to worry about
legitimate james is coming after me
why did you go why did you go on sean
hannity's show and make a fool of
yourself
i didn't make a fool of myself i was
there
i was there to defend myself and defend
defend the unfair
treatment
that my family has been receiving
oh so so you believe you believe just
like last night on sean hannity what
you're saying here is that you're being
treated unfairly because you committed
crimes and they're being investigated
possibly
yeah they're like coming after us
because they hate us they hate you or
because you committed crime
what crime do you know what do you know
what the word crime means
um
are you
is that like kremlin
no no no no no
i mean it can be it can't have to do
with russia but not everything has to do
with russia do you think everything has
to do with russia
well the democrats keep making it
hillary you know hillary's gonna turn
america in
into
this uh she she wants russia
what does she want about russia like
russian dressing on her salad or
or like what do you mean you know that
putin hates hillary that's why
putin really worked hard to support your
dad in 2016 and 2020.
what yeah putin loves your dad your dad
actually loves putin probably more than
putin loves him it's kind of like the
situation that you're in right you love
you love your dad way more than he loves
you your dad i love my daddy you love
you
i love my daddy
you you love your dad
do you think what is so funny do you
think your daddy loves don your brother
don
i don't know sometimes he calls him oh
hey what's your face what's your name
hey other one
the other powder knows he he says hey
hey hey hey blizzard face
hey
hey
hey hey hey kid who looks like casper
i i don't know
he just says his names
so he doesn't ever say don
what about booger sugar junior i like to
call your brother booger sugar junior
does he ever say that
i'm just seeing if my my uh my nicknames
are leaking through
what about sugar no no no never mind
never mind what about your sister ivanka
did she have to do does she know about
the crimes that the trump organization
has committed here oh
ivanka is pretty
ivanka no no no i i i get that she's
like my she's like my wife laura oh
smoking
[Laughter]
right but i don't know why you're
laughing i
right i get i get that you think your
your sister and your wife are pretty i
mean are they not pretty
they're fair and hot fair enough i'll
give you that what i'm asking though
what i'm asking though is did your
sister have anything to do with with the
criming stuff with committing crime
um
um
um can i plead the fifth again
no no well i mean you you can you don't
have to answer the question but this is
you're not under oath you're not under
oath here
yeah she did some crimes
oh
okay she did so this is not one or else
you said yeah right but it's not you're
not under oath so what kind of what kind
of my friend yeah before i came here
absolutely no you're my friend yeah
absolutely if you're gonna talk here
we'll let you talk here what what what
kind of crimes did she commit
oh well um
she and
don't tell anybody okay i won't tell
nobody promise cross my heart and hope
to die
she
she and jared um
they uh
yeah they did some um
they had some relations with foreign
entities
and anti-aunties and entities
and
right
i get it i get it i get it
go to your next thought if you have one
they made these deals um where they went
into these back rooms and then they were
like using private messaging servers and
stuff
and then i would be like
daddy what's going on please daddy
please and then
and then
she was like
no don't rap me out and then and then i
was like i'm not i'm just trying to make
sure that no one gets in trouble
so so she was scared that you would rat
her out in a deposition do you know what
a deposition is
i'm not depressed no no no no not
depression deposition where you go
before prosecutors and you
tell them what happened i was there i i
said i um i played the fifth like
i don't know like i mean is that why you
just say plead the fifth all the time is
because you're so used to saying it when
someone asks you
a question
well i was i was instructed that i
should say i played the fifth who who
were you instructed by
um
what's what's their name do you know the
name of the person
it's okay you can say it here you're
you're on live but you're not under oath
remember you can say anything you want
my dad your your dad
he said it so he didn't actually talk to
you he talked to you yeah this was last
this was 2020 when i did this deposition
yeah and i was like super sad and i was
like daddy please help me daddy please
and then he said
don't say word
please the fifth and i was like
what and he's like
don't say a [ __ ] word lead the fifth
and i was like
okay daddy
and then leticia james was super mean to
me in that room
they don't even give you juice
what kind of juice did you want apple
juice oh is that your favorite juice
eric is that your
apple juice do you like animal crackers
is it
i love animal crackers you do
yeah
do you ever do you ever have animal you
ever dip the animal crackers in the
apple juice i've never no this no i've
i've never i don't know you gotta try
man it's so good it really yeah is that
so that's what you're upset about that
tit james didn't give you apple juice
and animal crackers is that the well she
was really she was really mean she was
making all these accusations
she was accusing you of stuff right yeah
she was accusing me of stuff yeah and
she was accusing my family right
all these things what she's doing like
what things were she using
you guys improperly valued your company
what is what does that mean exactly do
you remember doing that
i i don't know i told you i just deliver
coffee and i made confetti sure i signed
autographs for people but i don't know
what's going on you don't know what's
going on at the trump organization you
just make confetti in the shredding room
and you deliver coffee what's in the
coffee there by the way is it decent
coffee or is it shitty coffee i is it
cheap i just mean eat the coffee grounds
you eat the coffee grounds no you're not
supposed to eat the coffee ground you
chew the coffee grounds and you pour hot
water in your mouth it's no no no no no
no no that's how you make that's how you
make coffee you nasty
okay let's get back on track here let's
get back on track you keep getting me
off track with the coffee grounds the
animal crackers and the apple juice
you're asking the questions yeah well
you're like leticia james i didn't get
the answer that i wanted tell me the
answers answer my questions answer my
questions
your dad did this your sister did this
you did this i don't know what's going
on guys okay it's like jeez give me a
second to breathe
so what was she accusing your sister of
doing ivan you're talking about ivanka
right not tiffany because you have you
have two sisters ivanka and tiffany
which which sister was she accusing
who's tiffany
you have a sister a half-sister named
tiffany
tiffany trump
never heard of her never heard of her
okay well so your sister ivanka jesus
christ your sister ivanka um
what what uh what was tish james
accusing her of
um
she was
she's she said that as one of the head
people of the organization that she was
the person that was behind it they said
that she might have been
the the mastermind
do you think your sister ivanka is a
mastermind i know you think she's pretty
but do you think she's a mastermind
i mean
i i don't know i don't know i mean like
don says that he's the powerful one and
then
and then sometimes
baron says that we're all idiots
and then you know
ivanka says she says sometimes
i'm gonna own this place someday and
it's like what does that even mean like
well i even have a job where do i live
how do i afford my penthouse and she
goes
don't worry about it
and it's like i don't know why these
people are no making them
and like just telling nice to me
[Music]
so
so here eric get it together get it
together
get it together would you please would
you please we're running out of time
here we got 10 minutes until the top of
the hour so yeah
i got 10 more minutes to talk to you
so do you want to respond to the uh
what you said last night on the hannity
show you know a lot of people on twitter
are really raking you through the coals
here they're calling you you know whiny
little [ __ ] and stuff is there anything
you'd like to tell the people out there
on twitter
i'm not a little [ __ ]
why are people so mean to me
i don't
[Music]
i went on this show last night and i was
proving myself and i wanted to prove to
my father and my family that i am a real
man
so you think you're a real man is it is
that why you went on sean hannity's yeah
it's like
okay cool i'm a real boy but like i'm a
real man who who doesn't think you're a
real man in your family my wife your
wife doesn't laura's like always like oh
why don't you just do more why don't you
grow up and you roll a pair of balls you
know i'll put some pants on why did you
be a real person and defend yourself
aren't you letting your cocoa brother
just put you around and your egotistical
sister just stop you like a little baby
[Laughter]
it's like i am a real person okay right
it's like at least i didn't steal money
from a puppy organization you know
so
so i seen a video on time speaking of
your wife
um she makes a lot of videos but there
was a video
of you and her on social media a while
back i don't know if it went on the
instagram or what but um she was doing
her makeup and you're holding the
brushes you seem to really know what
makeup brushes are which
do you do that a lot do you know
yeah all the time when i was a kid my
sister ivanka would say okay time to
play dress-up doll and then we'd go into
the room and then she was like okay
brush brush brush here's the foundation
here's the powder here's the mascara
here's the lipstick here's the eyeliner
oh we're going to crimp your eyelashes
we're going to tweeze your eyebrows
we're going to we're going to put some
filler on your lips
she was said it was great you know she
was like i'm going to i'm going to run
this place someday and i need to know
exactly what i need to do and she's like
this is how you're going to look and
you're my little person i'm going to
push you around and it was fun for a
while
so it's not fun anymore for her to push
you around is that what you're saying no
it's not she's fun it's not fun to do
that is she still pushing you around
ivanka or your wife
did they push you around
they're both hot
but right i i know i i know how you feel
about how they look i get that we went
over that already
sure they pushed me around but like
it's like i'm kind of like into it now i
don't even know
you don't like you have no idea
no it's like sometimes they push me
around i'm like oh that hurts and other
times i'm like
ow that hurts
and then and then and then they say oh
say daddy please and i'm like okay daddy
please and then we all smile and laugh
and it's amazing
they like to say oh daddy please is that
what you're yeah and you're not under
oath so you can say just about anything
you want here
on the show so um but what you're saying
is that ivanka and your wife say oh
daddy please is that is that what i'm
hearing yeah
yeah okay well
i appreciate sometimes sometimes don
will say oh i'll hear him on the phone
sometimes when i go over to visit him
like you know when we're like talking
about what we should say to people
and i mean uh what i mean um
i um
anyway um
you mean you need to get like your story
straight or
yeah he says like okay remember those
times we'd go camping and then like dad
would never show up so then we'd have to
make stories about what we were doing
that weekend with dad you know and and
then and then we would go back to school
and we say guys this weekend we hung out
with our dad he took us camping and we
made a fire and we made marshmallows and
s'mores and we cooked over the fire
so we had to make stories up and now
don and i meet up you know and
we talk about
what we need to tell people what do you
know he said it's just like those
campfire stories what do you mean you
need to tell people you mean like you
need to tell stories tell lies to people
because you're trying to hide something
or
what don don said we're not lying we're
helping
he said he said we're not lying he goes
we're not lying
and then sometimes he goes joe biden and
i just like
don't understand it because he's like we
have to make sure he's like we have to
make sure that joe biden gets out of
office and then i'm like what does this
even have to do with anything and then
he's like joe biden is all it's all
attached and then i'm like okay and so
then he's like we have to get our story
straight so that you know when people
come after us we aren't gonna go down
so
so you like the way he says joe biden
because i kind of like the way he says
joe biden is it
yeah he's like it's like
joe biden
it's it's it's it's a lot of fun to say
it's a lot of fun here's the thing i
don't really have a problem with joe
biden you know oh really you like it you
like joe you like joe joe's cool joe's
cool
but my my brother hates him and my dad
really hates him
why do you think your your brother hates
him
probably because
don told me one time that he secretly
has a crush on
hunter biden
a crush what do you mean a crush he was
like oh man
hunter biden gets actual love from his
father
not like us
oh so he's jealous of hunter biden
that's why he doesn't like joe cause joe
loves hunter is that
yeah it's like sure hunter screwed up
we're all screwed up you know like look
at my father he was never there with us
on camping trips but like here we are
making up stories about he was there on
camping trips and we have to just cope
into ways that we don't even know and
there's probably years of of of
emotional damage that has put distress
on us and now here we are and and hunter
has screwed up just like all of us but
the only difference between hunter biden
and joe biden and don jr and me and and
ivanka and that other person you said
tiffany i think and with with our father
trump the only difference is that joe
biden actually
loves his
son
yeah well i mean you know most fathers
do most fathers do love their sons
that's the thing that happens a lot even
if they're kind of flowers our dad
doesn't like to
be emotional
and i'm an emotional guy i i can tell i
can tell so so let's get back to your
dad and joe biden why why doesn't your
jo why does your dad like like joe biden
that much what's what what is it because
he thinks that
he he's like oh no look he's like oh no
look this guy is a better president than
me and i'm like dad it's like
what's going on what are you talking
about you were a great president you
made america great again and then you
made america great again again and he's
like doesn't matter doesn't matter joe
biden joe biden's the worst thing that
ever happened to this country he's a
cancer he can't even get words out
and then i'm like but but dad you also
have trouble getting words out
it takes you two hands to drink a glass
of water now he's like don't talk to me
so he does the uh thing that huh yeah
yeah
yeah you know you do you do it you do a
good impersonation of your your brother
don and your dad can you do ivanka
because you did you did laura and you
did ivanka
you do a pretty good impress
impersonation um sure okay okay um yeah
go ahead
just put the makeup on [ __ ]
that is that is that a bonker or is that
your wife laura
that was ivanka oh okay can you do your
wife laura did you do that one sure
just put the makeup on [ __ ]
eric i i really do appreciate you coming
on and um you know giving us all this
information i'm sure it'll be very
valuable to prosecutors um that are
looking into you your father and your
family business wait no you said you
said this wasn't on the record yeah i
was having a lot of fun i thought we
were going to be my friend
well we're live the problem is is i
can't un-publish it it's already out
there and on the interwebs do you know
what the interwebs are
you know what social media is do you
know how to do that type of thing um
no
um
no
um
i just
um
one time i was on the internet and i
watched this video and it said put the
lotion on the skin and i was like what
is this and then my
my sister was like get away from there
so your sister does the
thing too
yeah everyone in the family just goes
that's what that's what they do to you
yeah there i was just watching this
video and it was like put the lotion on
the skin and i was like what is this and
she was like
it's like i was just watching a video on
youtube
what's wrong i was just trying to watch
a video
well eric
is there anything else you'd like to
tell the audience or tell the world
before we have to
before we do you have to go soon are you
i mean like i gotta go pee in a second
oh okay
that must be all the apple juice huh
yeah do you know that apple juice and
pee are the same color
yeah i i know they're they're very
because one time when i was a kid
my brother and my sister did this joke
this practical joke they said and it was
like they're like hey eric how would you
try this warm apple sauce this worm
apple juice
and i was like what are you guys talking
about and then and then i was like okay
fine and then i drank it of course
because it was like it was warm and it
it's they said it was apple juice and
then
and it wasn't
okay it wasn't
what was it what was it do you think do
you think it was something that looked
like apple juice
i don't know they kept laughing at me
and they were like oh and they said it
was pee but i don't believe them they
wouldn't do that but then i find out
later that i find out my dad's also
going to pee and that was crazy oh
really so tell us tell us about
i know you have to go soon but tell us
please tell us about how your dad
was crazy
he was like i'm gonna go to russia and
i'm gonna talk to putin myself so he
went to russia and then i was like oh my
god
well can you bring me back some trinkets
and then he came back and then it turns
out that there was this tape that was
made and it was like it wasn't me it
wasn't me and i was like dad what are
you doing and then and then he was like
this tape on the internet it's not me
it's not me there's some trinkles
there's some showers it's golden and
then i was like
what and then he was like if you hear
anything it wasn't me fake news
and so then
people have said my dad's in a pee and
that he took
uh
this thing with pee in a bed and with
these
russian models
people are saying that people are people
been saying that for a long time i think
i think james comey actually uh briefed
your dad
um
when
i think he briefed him
when he was becoming president do you
remember that trump tower he actually
came and he briefed your dad on the um
yeah my dad picked him out of the office
again
okay
go make some confetti go get some coffee
oh really so you became confetti coffee
boy at that point when um yeah and
here's the thing spoiler that's where
kofi comes from oh really so coffee is
coffee confetti is that the
mm-hmm
okay well
breaking news i appreciate it you've
been wondering here i am under wraps
can't talk about it well here you go
folks
go fave that's what it's from
that's fantastic i'm glad you cleared
that up for us because the world was
wondering exactly what a lot of people
on twitter these days i read the tweets
that come at me everyone's always like
your dad said go fave your dad said go
fave well here's the thing he meant it
he put it there on purpose okay because
he is a genius
oh eric
you're killing me man you're killing me
um
how much longer do you have to hang out
and i could probably hold my bladder for
like a few more minutes a few hours okay
so so the apple the apple juice is not
uh is not an urgent then nature is not
calling urgency
if i really need to i'll just do it
right here
oh okay so so do you because it's like
super super warm you know and it feels
good it feels really good and you're
like oh yeah because like sometimes when
we go camping you know without my dad
and my and i was there with my brother
you know it'd be like oh no the fire
went out how do we stay warm and then
the guy that was watching us was like
just be your pants
the guy that was watching you what what
what do you mean the guy that was
watching you
i don't know he was just like some
employee
some employee huh took you guys camping
is that is that the story that you told
that who was your dad did you pretend he
was your dad when when he was there
yeah yeah i did i mean it was like i had
to say it was my dad you know and my dad
was able to do this and do that and i
had to i had to make up stories because
when the kids when you come back to
school you never be like what'd you do
this weekend and i said we went camping
with my dad and people like what are you
talking about i saw him on fifth avenue
and i was like
no you didn't and then i would have to
make up some lie about how we made a
fire and and made s'mores and cooked
food and caught fish
and
were were men of the land
oh so so so you make up these stories
that you're that you're manly
is that why don junior wears flannel now
i noticed that in the last few years
your brother don jr has switched to
flannel he went from you know your fake
cheap-ass suits to uh flannel he's got
the al borland look i mean you're kind
of doing it too you got the beard going
you know you got the old 1990s out
borland look going but
is that why you switched to flannel
shirts
no that's because he has sensitive
nipples
his what he has sensitive nipples the
shirts
that we make from trump are very rough
okay are they the trump shirts that are
made in china that come over here very
rough on the skin and they were causing
irritations he actually had an allergic
reaction and it caused his nipples to
chafe so now he has to use flannel
because it's much softer so he goes and
buys a ll bean from jcpenney
so you know you know that you can
you can wear an undershirt underneath
your shirt so you don't chafe the nip
never mind
no because my dad said
you gotta touch the skin
you gotta touch it you put the lotion on
the skin and you put the shirt to the
skin
trump to trump touch it
okay so that's what he said
so he doesn't want you to use
undershirts i i get that so let me get
back to don jr and flannel shirts
because i find it i mind it amusing when
he does these videos on instagram have
you ever seen your brother's videos on
this instagram
no
you've never seen don junior's videos on
instagram where he's he's looking down
at note cards and he's talking into the
camera and he says weird things oh i've
seen the ones on facebook oh is it
facebook okay facebook instagram
whatever the hell it is but you've seen
these videos that he does uh-huh yeah
what do you think about the videos that
your brother does
have you ever considered doing these
videos i'm usually in the room and i'm
the one directing and i'm like
okay
eyes up
open eyes open
open your eyes
so
i'm there i'm like i'm like a real
hollywood director
so what else do you tell him when you're
directing
do you direct him to to not snort as
much coke beforehand or does he try to
do as
much drugs before he presses record
i've never seen him do any drugs i just
show up and he's got he's like i got all
these like he's like i got all these
ideas about joe biden about ukraine all
this stuff and so then i go there and
he's already like it's like he's had
like 10 cups of coffee you know and so
then you think it's so you think it's
the coffee that's that's got him all
jacked up
maybe maybe he's shredding documents and
having coffee i don't even know but what
i will say is whenever i go over there
to direct him to make these little home
videos he is already going he's like a
million miles a minute and then i have
to catch up so i'm chewing coffee beans
and i'm pouring hot water in my mouth
and i'm making mouth coffee
and then he starts filming and then i go
okay okay quick ready look up look up
smile smile wipe the tears from your
eyes okay and
action
and then he and then he's like joe biden
and i'm like perfect and then after that
you know he he he does uh
between takes you know he's got to blow
his nose a lot you know he'd sometimes
get bloody noses which is kind of gross
but he says it's because the altitude
so the altitude where in florida the
altitude in florida gives them bloody
noses is it
he said it's like sub-level altitude i
don't know listen i'm not a scientist
okay but what i will say is i help them
make those videos and i think that they
could win an oscar
so so you consider yourself a filmmaker
because you showed up while don junior's
doing his selfie videos for facebook is
it
yeah what i mean i even i even write the
note cards for him i write it to you
is that the ones he's looking at because
he can't remember yeah he can't remember
to say joe biden
yeah and those those cards are just
one
word per card so it's like
joe
biden
you know like is that why so it so is
that why he says it like that
zayn
is that why he says it like that
yeah yeah
because i i i i
didn't that's what i do in the cards
okay so so do you add in letters on the
cards so you'll draw it out like that
yeah okay yeah i do um um
what i like to call
funetical
spelling
fun magical
fun
because it's fun or because it's fun i
mean that's what my tutor taught me um i
mean we still kind of go on a daily
basis about it but
um i'll see you guys
you're still being tutored
uh-huh
yeah okay well that makes sense that
makes sense
and eric
did you piss your pants or or you need
to go to the bathroom what's the
i just checked i didn't
you didn't okay no but i i i do need to
go um because uh i need to talk with don
about like you know
campfire stories
campfire stories yeah that's what we
call it when we need to um figure out
what we need to say to people
okay well i'll let you and don
work on your campfire stories i really
appreciate you joining us uh come back
anytime seriously you are welcome here
to um
uh to say whatever you would like on air
um
so everyone can hear your voice because
you know you have the first amendment
which is the freedom of speech you know
that's the first one right right and
then if i if i put two second amendments
yeah um
yes yes we know we don't think thank you
eric for joining us thank you um
audience stay with us we'll
we'll be right back
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
headline
[Music]
under president joe biden the american
economy adds 467
000 new jobs in the month of january
thanks brandon
[Music]
[ __ ] em
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
oh
holy [ __ ]
[Music]
well
you heard it right here on let's talk to
tony michael's podcast
he had um
not the youngest brother but the younger
of the two brothers that you'd like to
see oh and we can still get his name up
here see i just didn't work on this
oh my god how did you guys like eric
trump as our guest
on the tony michaels podcast that's
something else huh i can't believe he
gave us
over 30 minutes of his time he let us
know a lot of things i hope i hope eric
comes back eventually i really do hope
he um
he makes an appearance back here
oh
well
i should have did an extended break to
compose myself that was um that was
something else so let's get back to the
shitless roundup here um let me
let me respond to the the video of eric
trump on on um hannity
so you heard it from him but but here's
the thing is uh in all all seriousness
because you know
you know we're real serious here on the
show
uh
eric trump it seems very afraid he
seemed very afraid on sean hannity's
show last night not on my show but he
seems very very very afraid
that
that it seems like tisch james and not
only tish james but possibly
the manhattan d.a
and the feds are going to catch on
to this accounting story um that's why
john
durham is doing what they're doing
that's why fox news keeps saying hillary
clinton email lady email lady
email lady russia russia email lady
that's that's the whole game
they're trying to distract their viewers
from what's coming
they're trying to distract the country
from what's coming
that's the rub here
that's what the [ __ ]
canadian trucker thing is about
it's all a distraction
and it's all to plant seeds in people's
minds that democracy doesn't work here's
here's how it works
john durham puts out a [ __ ] court
document it gets circulated oh look he's
accusing her of this even though there's
no evidence he can't provide any [ __ ]
evidence in the court document that he
bought
then what happens is you get these [ __ ]
in the right wing media oh email ladies
going down she's gonna go to prison they
have to lock her up
they must lock her up lock her up you
remember they were chanting it this is
it this is the evidence this is the
smoking gun that john durham has which
is no evidence at all
and then what happens
what happens is hillary clinton isn't
prosecuted because there's nothing to
[ __ ] prosecute her for
there's nothing
to prosecute her for
the email lady was not the president the
email lady is not going to prison that's
not a thing at least right now with the
evidence that you don't have
hillary clinton
is going to remain free to be a citizen
she's not elected to any office as
far as i can tell
nor is she seeking an office
so their plan is is to say
that merrick garland
listen to me listen to me when i tell
you this left wing people
people out there that are in resist
they're gonna make merrick garland the
enemy
okay
they know right now that the left the
democrats the democratic coalition is
very very frustrated with merrick
garland
okay
are you following the road i'm stepping
down are you smelling what i'm stepping
in
so
when these big twitter accounts out
there are saying disparaging stuff
against the attorney general of the
united states merrick garland
they're going to use that
as weapons
against democracy
okay you follow me that's where this is
headed that's their plan here
their plan your mark my [ __ ] words
mark my words they will be quoting rob
reiner don winslow and lawrence tribe
mark my words
well they said well they said the left
wing said well look what the left says
merrick garland this merrick garland
that
because they've known that the game on
january 6 is run amok
and the reason why is because the the
the populace
is not mad
that they're looking into donald trump
they're mad that they're not prosecuting
him and they're mad at merrick garland
because of [ __ ] it's complete
[ __ ] it's all nonsense there's
almost 800 conviction 800 indictments
and several convictions there are people
right now sitting in federal prison
right now in federal prison
for january six
doj has not done nothing there are 11
oath keepers who are indicted under
conspiracy to commit sedition
and we see new evidence leaking every
day of the sedition that they committed
stewart rhodes the founder of the oath
keepers
who were part of this conspiracy to
commit sedition
testified before the january 6 select
committee which is the political
investigation which is the way the
republicans wanted it
that's what republicans wanted democrats
didn't want the political investigation
republicans wanted it
so the game here is to try to turn
to try to turn the story
that you should be mad at a.g garland
because he's not prosecuting rich people
including hillary clinton
do you see what do you see what they're
going to do
do you see what their plan is
are you catching on to what the 2022
midterm is
you're gonna he'll hear hillary clinton
and merrick garland's name a lot
a lot
and merrick garland is gonna get front
billing on every right-wing [ __ ]
trash that there is
they're gonna make you [ __ ] hate
merrick garland
because they want you to spread their
right wing propaganda that merrick
garland isn't prosecuting people
that's what they're going to do
so if you're out there listening and you
want donald trump and all his ilk and
the january 6 and people to pay for what
happened on january 6 and even before
that during the 2016 election
if you think it's a good idea to take
right what will be right wing talking
points very [ __ ] soon i'm talking by
the end of the day
mark it down by the end of the day
if you want to propagate right wing
talking points go ahead
but i'm telling you what politically
they're doing here
politically they're trying to they're
trying to make it to where moderates and
independents in this country who don't
know news stories
who don't know news stories
to be on the side of the gqp
and they're using the outrage of the
left to do it
that's what they're going to do the the
false
stupid ass outrage of the left
that's how they're going to play this
game
you don't think so you think oh well
tony there's no way they could do that
then they'd have to explain away why
he's not prosecuting trump why would
they explain that away
why they don't give a [ __ ] about the
truth they don't care about the truth
they're not gonna care about the truth
because the truth is they're [ __ ]
hypocrites and they'll use any means
necessary to take power in this country
even if it means to completely [ __ ]
lie and to convince to convince people
on the left to convince people in the
middle to convince moderates
independents people who aren't political
at all that don't pay attention to
politics
they're gonna pump it into the brains of
people that merrick garland doesn't
prosecute powerful people you know like
hillary clinton
and that's a good reason to vote for
republican because republicans will hold
merrick garland accountable
mark my words
so
when you're out there tweeting when
you're out there talking and you're
talking about messaging because we talk
about messaging a lot
a lot we talk about messaging
they're about to appropriate
the left-wing outrage of merrick garland
that's what they're doing the fake
outrage of the left
about merrick garland
so i'm not saying to go delete your
their disparaging merrick garland tweets
because you're welcome to your tweets
you're welcome to your right i mean i'm
frustrated with the whole thing too with
the timing
but should we be should we be frustrated
with the timing of this
think about this for a second
let's say let's say they appropriate
them the message that merrick garland
isn't prosecuting people which is
exactly what they're doing
that's that's what they're gonna do
i can already see it
i can already tell what they're gonna do
let's just say they appropriate that
message
that merrick garland is not doing enough
merrick garland bad need to replace
merrick garland
what would be better
than merrick garland filing charges
against
donald trump and the january 6 and
whoever else the trump organization
the the [ __ ] 2016 inaugural committee
i mean god damn the list goes on and on
and on and on
with these [ __ ] people crying and
[ __ ]
possibly the [ __ ] trump pump and dump
that the social media [ __ ] the true
social whatever the [ __ ] that thing is
that [ __ ] scam
all the credit card scams that the trump
campaign committed during the entire
[ __ ] 2020 campaign when they were
defrauding people out of their life
savings
look
if you want to know the messaging that
they're about to that they're about to
tell everyone and spread around the
nation and the media's gonna help them
do this
trust me the media is not they have not
caught on they're still in the [ __ ]
trump loop
they're gonna be talking about hillary
clinton for [ __ ] weeks
[ __ ] weeks they're gonna be talking
about [ __ ] emails
and russia watch
watch
just playing into the minds and into the
message of the [ __ ] of the fascist in
this country
i i'm not going to i'm going to tell you
exactly what they're doing
the right wing is trying to appropriate
the message that merrick garland isn't
doing enough
starts with tisch james it starts with
this thing it starts with that thing oh
merrick garland needs to be replaced
what's the best way
if you want to replace merrick garland
where you can impeach him impeachment
garland
for not prosecuting hillary
i can already see it it's like right
there it's right in front of you it's
right in front of you
it's right in front of you
they're going to take tweets they're
going to take tweets
from people who want merrick garland to
prosecute donald trump and they're going
to use that in their appropriation of
this message to impeach merrick garland
and the best way to do that is to vote
republican
vote for the fascist
we'll get rid we'll get rid of joe biden
kamala harris
and merrick garland we're gonna impeach
him we're gonna make donald trump the
speaker of the house
and he'll appoint he'll appoint an
attorney general which is not a thing
the speaker does but they don't give a
[ __ ] they don't care
and the real issue that we have in this
country is an education problem problem
because most people will believe that
[ __ ] because they don't know what the
[ __ ] happens they don't know how it
works unfortunately it's a reality that
we live in
they have no clue how this works
but if you don't think the next six
months is going to be about hillary and
her emails and merit garland not
prosecuting you you're not paying
attention and is exactly what is going
to happen you can hate on me all you
want oh you're alright
he's not doing it
whatever
almost 800 prosecutions so far for
daniel 6 there's 11 11 oath keepers
including the founder of the oath
keepers who were charged with seditious
conspiracy
which is bound to end up in superseding
indictments and more conspiracy
because it wasn't just those 11 people
more than likely
that were on those conference calls
trying to plan how they were going to
take over the government once the
insurrection act was signed
they didn't just [ __ ] come up with
this idea themselves you heard dakota
adams
on my show
stuart rhodes is a strange son dakota
adams said on my show that stewart
rhodes wrote in their credo that the
insurrection act was against their
their beliefs they did not they thought
that it would be a coup
stewart rhodes the founder of the oak
keepers did a 180 on the insurrection
act and martial law
now presumably to maybe protect his own
ass from something else
i'm telling you
i'm telling you and i know i know and i
i don't want to have to say i told you
so to people but i will i'll [ __ ] say
i told you so i'll play the [ __ ] clip
back over and over and over again
they're going to appropriate the message
that merrick garland isn't doing his job
to prosecute people and he needs to be
impeached and the only way to impeach
him is to elect fascist
look he's not he's not prosecuting he's
not prosecuting really powerful people
america including hillary clinton which
you know she's evil remember you voted
against her for trump she's evil oh the
email lady email email email email look
durham he filed a court document oh
merrick garland needs to go merrick
garland needs to go the only way to get
him to go is to vote for republican vote
for fascist you need fascism
but tony they won't do that because then
they'll have to explain they don't give
a [ __ ] about explaining trump in that
situation they don't care
i mean god damn they bitched about
supply chains for [ __ ] a year now and
now they want to lock up supply chains
you think these people [ __ ] make
sense they're down in dallas still
waiting for jfk junior to show up
they don't give a [ __ ] about reality
they don't care about truth they will
win by any means necessary to make us a
fascist state they want totalitarianism
that's what they want
and the reason why we have such a
struggle in this country is because it's
a minority ideology
most people in this country want
democracy rather they realize it or not
they do
they want democracy rather they realize
it or not
now a lot of them are being duked into
thinking that democracy is something
that it isn't
it's a big education problem that we
have in this country
and abroad
and it's all the [ __ ] putin talking
points right before you
it's all the [ __ ] putin playbook
right before you
to call blue red and red blue and make
you believe it
it will work
if we let it
it will work if we let it
well that's pro-democracy people this us
people out there that are pro-democracy
minded that know we live in a democracy
and want this to remain a democracy not
a fascist state
we have to stick together in this
situation
yeah we may disagree on what the minimum
wage may be we may disagree on how or
when or how much to cancel student debt
we may disagree on health care or or
kids starting school at three instead of
five and how much money you get for
college and who you get we may disagree
on all those line item things
but if you let them propagate their
message about merit garland which
they're about to do
if you let them propagate and
appropriate that message of merit
garland
and the only way to to do this is to not
not amplify their talking point
you're going to sow doubt into
institutions that's not
pro-democracy and i wish people on the
internet who had really big [ __ ]
influential counts would stop saying
anti-democracy [ __ ]
showing doubt in an institution like the
department of justice because you don't
like the outcome is not
pro-democracy it's not
and you're hurting democracy and you're
hurting the chance for democracy is what
you're doing when you do that
and mind you now the fascists are going
to take advantage of it now that they
have this little court document that
john durham has signed or submitted to
the court
they're gonna do it
they're gonna do it that's what fascists
do trust me
all right let's take a quick break
we'll be right back with more [ __ ] list
roundup right after this
be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you annoyed by masks infringing on
your rights do you wish you didn't have
to comply with biden's communist mask
mandate are you tired of wearing masks
that actually fit your face
well now you don't have to be
introducing the droop with our patented
droop technology every mask is uniquely
molded to not fit your face just send us
a selfie and we'll have one of our
troopests mold the mask for you elastic
free thanks to the droop i don't even
need to pull my mask on anymore it just
sags that way the droop lets you
customize from a selection of pre-worn
masks lipstick stains included make sure
to order your droop today drew be the
spread you want to see in the world
catch tony's twitch stream the [ __ ] list
roundup at twitch.tv slash the tony
michaels
we're back to the king of brilliant this
is the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
more news on sedition
on the january 6 select committee
more news coming in um as you know rudy
giuliani grandpa farty mcsharty rudy
giuliani the one that can't get his uh
legal fees paid by the cheeto dust
mobster grandpa poopy pants himself
donald trump is cooperating
with the
january 6 select committee um you got
john cooper here saying breaking let's
make this a little bigger so you can see
it breaking the january 6 select
select committee says giuliani will
cooperate fully
not a very good week for donald trump
yeah
every week gets worse and worse for him
um and
we've seen
we've seen earlier eric trump as well um
so and this is breaking course this was
kind of the news but it sounds like it's
getting more and more official there's
some reporting on it
um as you know
rudy giuliani was in the war room the
day of january 6. he was there with
john eastman he was there with christina
bob which a lot of people take her for
granted and just kind of breeze over
christina bob and who christina bob is a
lot of people know her as an oan
reporter she's not just an oan reporter
that's all [ __ ] nonsense that's all
that's all that's all just trying to get
you to not pay attention she's a lawyer
she's a highly educated lawyer she also
worked in the government before
before the summer of 2020 during the
2020 campaign when she went to oan and
she worked at department of homeland
security
so as a former dhs official as an
attorney
and as the oan reporter that everyone
makes her out to be she was in the war
room with rudy giuliani and john eastman
and it's been shown that she wrote
and helped dictate
some of the plans that day for the
alternate slate of electors
to carry out the john eastman memo the
cheeto dust kangaroo coup as it were
attempt
it wasn't it wasn't successful
but it was an
attempt uh let's see if we can find some
of course it does look like he's going
to cooperate and it looks like the
january 6 select committee for whatever
reason and i tried to go to their page
to see if they confirmed this but it
looks like the january 6 select
committee is confirming that yes rudy
giuliani is fully cooperating now what
that full crop cooperation means rather
they're actually going to
ask him questions about the war room
that day i guess that will be that will
be what we want to know um some other
stuff in the news prince andrew as we
said earlier breaking news prince andrew
settled a sexual abuse case against
virginia uh guilford i think is her name
um one of jeffrey epstein's accusers
she's the one she's one of the ones that
actually uh appeared as a witness
in in the uh
glistening max with just glistening
jillstein i don't know maxwell's case um
and uh but there was you know we've had
michael popock on to explain this she
was she's in australia and they were
trying to file and they didn't want to
file um it's actually out of out of new
york manhattan new york is where this
court filing was but it looks like um
they've come to a financial
settlement
uh and the financial terms have not been
disclosed
so there's the new york times article
i'll retweet that um
it it it appears that prince andrew and
the royal family are willing to pay
whatever they need to pay uh to make
sure that the truth doesn't get out here
uh brooklyn dad says breaking prince
andrew has agreed to settle out of court
in the sexual abuse case hope she gets a
ton from this nasty creep yeah i mean i
i want her to get truckloads of money
this virginia
um guy free gift free i don't know how
to say her last name um virginia i hope
that she gets a lot of [ __ ] money
truckloads and truckloads and i hope she
took him for almost the whole [ __ ]
crown jewels [ __ ] those [ __ ]
not only [ __ ] him for doing what he did
but [ __ ] that the royal family for
trying to protect his ass um they did
finally you know push him aside
um but they protected him for a long
time knowing this [ __ ] um but hopefully
she gets
truckloads of money
um let's see what else do we have here
of course we'll have some really [ __ ]
stupid shitty takes i'm sure
because it's a jeffrey epstein case and
these [ __ ] right wingers can't help
but just you know
doing vile stupid stuff about
um these cases here
and probably even defending prince
andrew when you um
so the other case that's uh it's
trending number two is remington um
remington actually came to an agreement
for a major settlement um the gun
manufacturer remington about the ar-15
um
it's the first time that a gun
maker has ever been held accountable for
a mass shooting uh let's see we have
kyle here now breaking hartford
connecticut this is an ap report
remington to pay
73 million dollars in the settlement for
the families of the stanley hook schools
shooting victims um this could be
a really
a really uh
good president to set that yes you can
you can sue and you can win a financial
set of settlement for a company that is
not only manufacturing weapons of war
but marketing them as something
completely different and marketing them
to young white men who are committing
these atrocious shootings and killing
children in schools and keeping our
schools unsafe making parents worry
every day is it going to be my kid that
gets shot and killed at a school where
they're supposed to be safe yeah when
finally maybe we'll we'll have some
accountability with this and hope
hopefully this will this will be a
waterfall of these type of lawsuits and
we can stop these gun manufacturers just
to make the decision not to do this that
it's not financially uh it's shitty that
we have to use profit to go after these
[ __ ] but whatever we have to do
if we have to cut into their profits to
make sure that children aren't killed in
schools fine [ __ ] them that's what we
gotta do we have to keep our kids safe
we have to do it at all at all costs at
all means necessary we have to keep
children safe in schools from being shot
and mowed down by a goddamn weapon of
war for [ __ ] sake this is 2022 in the
in the united states of america and we
can't even [ __ ] manage to make sure
that school children are safe
from getting shot with bullets for
[ __ ] sake
it's not [ __ ] rocket science it
really isn't that hard
it isn't
this is all because republicans not
democrats republicans won't do [ __ ]
they won't do [ __ ] about guns in this
country and gun safety in this country
they won't do background checks they're
against at all and the reason why is
because of profit
it's profitable to be against background
checks
a lot of money goes into and a lot of
money is made when people who can't pass
a background check and buy weapons
it's [ __ ] stupid it's enough of this
[ __ ] [ __ ]
good guy bad guy [ __ ] [ __ ] that [ __ ] we
don't have to listen to it any longer
let's just go after their profits let's
do that
tristan also says uh breaking gun maker
gun maker remington agrees to 73 million
dollar settlement in the sandy hook with
the sandy hook families
watershed moment
first settlement with a gun manufacturer
or gun maker for a mass shooting it
definitely will not be the last exactly
cut into their [ __ ] profits maybe the
ar-15 won't be as profitable as they
thought
huh what do you think let's just keep
[ __ ] hacking away at their profits
that's what they care about that's what
we can use against them
dear gun nuts adios arf ar-15 remington
down thank you bad company
good way of saying it
so few words we're 41 minutes into this
second hour got about 19 minutes left
here on the air remember
every single weekday monday through
friday
noon eastern 11 central right here on
youtube twitter twitch so don't forget
to subscribe to the youtube channel and
follow us on twitter you know you don't
want to miss um especially the bonehead
of the week poll we'll probably be
putting that out today at tony michael's
pod that's where we do the bone ahead of
the week you can also watch the show
here on on at tony michael's pod channel
you can follow me at the johnny michaels
and follow gabe at i am gabe sanchez you
definitely don't want to miss that
if you missed the uh eric eric trump uh
interview i will cut that and put it on
the youtube channel for later so go over
there and make sure to subscribe
if you want to re-watch the eric trump
interview speaking of gabe sanchez gabe
was supposed to join us today but it was
eric trump instead
that's how it goes that's how it goes
everyone's having fun today uh everyone
likes the uh the eric trump um
everyone's saying hi to chris hi chris n
we're glad you're here we're glad chris
in is here everyone knows that
chris n used to um hate watch but i
think he's getting i think he's getting
used to it by now okay let's see what
else do we have um i want to go through
some more topics here let's see we had
uh
oh the roots picnic is it still trending
i wanted to talk about that for a second
um there's also this zero hedge let's
make this bigger there we go zero hedge
um the ap result reports
if i can make it
if i can get my zoom to work u.s
intelligence officials allege a
conservative financial website with a
significant u.s readership is amplifying
kremlin propaganda you don't say you
don't say that conservatives republicans
the gqp the cue and honors
are propagating kremlin propaganda come
on
it couldn't be you can't have actual
united states setting senators
propagating
kremlin propaganda no way that's not a
thing that could happen the [ __ ] out of
here with this [ __ ] officials said zero
hedge with 1.2 trillion
excuse me 1.2 million twitter followers
publish articles created by a moscow
controlled media
i wonder i wonder if members of congress
and members of the senate
i wonder i wonder if they're getting
their briefings written
by uh
russian controlled media it really does
seem like it ron johnson
rand paul
and speaking of russians and russian
propaganda and spreading it around i'm
sure she's still trending tulsi was
trending earlier and
[ __ ] trunt uh let's see where is she
where are you tulsi she claims to be a
[ __ ] democrat she's not no goddamn
democrat
shane pro-democracy
she's pro-russia
she's pro-russia she's not pro-democracy
at all not even [ __ ] close
i'm sick of hearing that [ __ ]
um that she is she's not
oh i used to like kelsey what the [ __ ]
did you like about her
bonehead [ __ ] bonehead is what she is
we don't have to put up with that [ __ ]
neither
let's see if i can
pull up her thread here
there we go
she's not trending anymore but i
definitely want to talk about this since
we're on the oh that's not it
there we go boom shakalaka
okay there's a video of her somewhere
here
here she is
here she is oh look she even [ __ ]
tweeted it out
what an idiot what a [ __ ] bonehead
this is what this one is
i call her trunk because i think it runs
like a trump
[ __ ]
i'm not afraid to say it
[ __ ]
now the durham investigation makes clear
that hillary clinton and the power elite
spied on the trump campaign in the white
house
oh my god
hillary clinton was a candidate she was
not the president of the united states
she held no official public office jesus
christ undermining our democracy see
this see they use these phrases
to get people to doubt that we have a
democracy
that's what they're doing that's what
the [ __ ] they're doing i'm telling you
this is what they're gonna do
this this is going to switch
from hillary clinton to merrick
garland's not doing anything about
hillary clinton fast quick and then
hurry by the end of the day you'll
probably find a tweet right now if you
go search if you go shirts launching us
into the coal in the new cold war
endangering americans in the world
clinton and her warmongers must be held
accountable see
see what i'm telling you your [ __ ]
tweet sucks
tulsi it [ __ ] sucks the [ __ ] out of
here with this [ __ ]
no one wants to hear this garbage
she went on of course you know here's
the clip let's let's see what this
[ __ ] idiot has to say
manufacture this russian collusion lie
actively undermining our democracy and
stoking the fires moving us into this
new cold war with russia okay exactly
what putin would want her to say exactly
what putin would want her to say [ __ ]
stupid ass
okay let's see if there's any more um
boo boo boo boo boo boo
oh
[ __ ] tulsi gabriel okay so that that
that that concludes the russian
propaganda
so it's not just the zero whatever zero
hedge or whatever the [ __ ] it is
they have they have a twitter account
apparently
is that what i'm understanding
um people let's go to their where's
their [ __ ] twitter account
do we know what it's called
says they have a twitter account i don't
know [ __ ] them okay
the twitter swindler the twitter slender
you guys seen this this show
on um
on netflix it's a good one
wait
that was that was a tender
swindler what is this the twitter
swindler i wonder what this is
do what is this why is twitter swindler
uh trending
and did it do
you got the handle there mj mj says yeah
they have 1.2 million followers you got
the handle
kalyn yoda anyone got the handle
anybody got the handle out there
let's see um durham's still trending of
course durham's still is trending at 17.
the thing that really pisses me off is
this uh the mizar story the accounting
story is dropped off the list
that's right
can you [ __ ] even imagine if hillary
clinton's accounting firm dropped her
because there was 10 years of [ __ ]
[ __ ] records financial records that
they submitted and now they're not
willing to stand behind them not only in
a civil court but in the criminal court
of law can you imagine that
can you [ __ ] a man we would be
talking about this for months [ __ ]
months we'd be talking about this [ __ ]
we you wouldn't be able to go anywhere
you wouldn't be able to go to the
[ __ ] grocery store
the [ __ ] grocery store
you wouldn't be able to go to the
grocery store at all
or or walmart or
the gas station you wouldn't be able to
talk to anyone at your work without did
you hear the hillary clinton is counting
she's criminals she's crooked
emails emails emails emails
emails emails
yeah well
kaelin was up all night making a thread
she says
she needs to take a nap
she's making a threat about the the
mizars
uh anyone want to see the
kaelin kaelin wants us to look at the
thread from mizar's she did she did a
really big thread about it huge thread
they even have uh mizar's university
she found that caitlyn worked hard on
this thread let's go look at let's see
it's here somewhere
i retweeted it there it is right here
here's the thread lots done pack
the former guy calamari and cali mari
junior is this the people who do that
who own the [ __ ]
the company the accounting firm is that
what it is
is that what it is
is that what it is calamari and calamari
dream this sounds familiar
don and don jr come on
are you [ __ ] serious are you [ __ ]
serious jesus christ
of course there's a lot of letters and
this this stuff has been this stuff has
been out here in the public for a long
time like she found some tweets from
back in 2018 when people are talking
about this um so go go look at this this
thread
she wants me to probably read it right
here on there of course we're 50 minutes
into the hour but go take a look at this
thread um here we'll we'll put it at the
top of the thing
this
red
on
mazar is that what it's called mazars
and it's mazers
gotta get it right
you gotta get it right all right there
we go tweet
thanks for your thanks for your thread
thanks for your thread caitlyn
caitlin with the research yeah no [ __ ]
yoda
like she i'm telling you like it's a
long thread there's a lot of [ __ ] in
there go take a look at it
um
tony says it was very good it is a very
good thread you got to go check out this
thread she put it together
it is huge there's a lot of stuff and
there's a lot of tweets there's a lot of
rabbit holes so beware you know you
might you might need about 30 45 maybe
even 50 minutes hour maybe hour and a
half probably an hour and a half
probably an hour and a half for this
thread because there's going to be a lot
of rabbit holes that you're going to get
into a lot of [ __ ] that you're going to
have to read about this accounting firm
that has told the trump organization to
[ __ ] off this is very significant like
this is one of the top stories that we
should be talking about
right here not about [ __ ] durham or
hillary clinton that's all distraction
and the distraction is that their
accounting firm is cooperating with
investigators on two investigations one
is civil which will bring down the trump
organization for sure
rather the criminal investigation is
successful or not and the two is the
criminal investigation in the manna and
da's office now here's the thing
here is the thing if we if we
if we think that if they committed
federal crimes in the manhattan d.a or
tish james the attorney general
they find that they committed federal
crimes that they're not going to refer
to those
[ __ ] and [ __ ] they are
definitely going to refer those to the
southern district of new york which
would more than likely have jurisdiction
over the trump organization
yep
that's a thing the other thing that
they're looking into is also ties to tom
barrack you guys remember tom barrack is
under federal indictment
and tom barrett kind of shows up and his
indictment is about saudi money being
being and
put into the trump campaign foreign
dollars being put into the trump
campaign
but there was a lot of money that seemed
to appear in the 2016 inaugural
committee
he had a lot to do with it ivanka trump
had a lot to do with it so did alan
weisselberg
and we know alan weiselberg is a cfo of
trump organization
and we know that he is under criminal
indictment in the manhattan da's office
for fraud financial fraud and tax fraud
and also the trump organization itself
is criminally indicted
and their accounting firm is talking
cooperating not only that they're
retracting their financial statements
that they put together for the
organization that is under criminal
indictment which donald trump grandpa
poopy pants the cheeto dust mobster
their orange mussolini jesus ran for
decades
hillary clinton's campaign did
opposition research
like they all do you [ __ ] boneheads
this really is not complicated this is
really not hard to understand why donald
trump and his allies wanted him to stay
the president united states
there's a lot of power that comes with
the president united states he's even
said it in the last few weeks you can
pardon people from federal crimes he did
pardon people from federal crimes he
pardoned roger stone he pardoned mike
flynn he pardoned steve bannon
he pardoned roger manafort
he pardoned the guy with the inaugural
committee hmm
seems kind of convenient doesn't it
he didn't pardon any of the people that
broke into the capitol not [ __ ] one
of them
stewart rhodes
stewart rhodes the guy who's charged
with condition seditious conspiracy
the one who was going to try to take
over the government when
donald trump enacted the insurrection
act because black lives matter antifa
got out of hand so i don't know what the
[ __ ] their plan was it's all on the go
look at the powerpoint they powerpointed
the [ __ ] they powerpointed the coup
he didn't pardon him either he could
have pardoned stuart rhodes why not
why wouldn't he
that's that's not that's not what
fascists do
you see they don't they don't do that
it's not how it's not how it works
but here we have
a very big story like this should be the
headline everywhere
like every water cooler
at every [ __ ] cash register
every vending machine
every place where a person is belly to
belly in every text thread every chat
this should be trending number one
for weeks and weeks on end that the
former president of the united states
donald j trump
and the business that he ran is under
criminal indictment
and in those investigations the
accounting firm that filed financial
records for him
fraudulent it seems because they've
retracted them
is retracting them and cooperating with
the investigation look
i'm sure the people at the accounting
firm didn't want to be on the defense
side of things there's two sides in a
prosecution and a court case whether
it's civil or criminal you can either be
part of the prosecution or you can be
part of the defense that's how it works
there's no other side like there's no
other side in a courtroom when you're in
a [ __ ] court case
civil or criminal you're either part of
the prosecution or you're part of the
defense you're not you can't you're not
both you're either one or the other and
i'm sure that the accounting it seems it
seems like it just seems like from the
reporting if it's true that they're
retracting the stories which is a public
statement that they put out
that yes
we're part of the prosecution
the accounting firm for the trump
organization which is under criminal
indictment in the state of new york and
under civil investigation in the state
of new york for fraud tax fraud
financial fraud their accounting the
people who did their accounting for
their financials
are part of the prosecution now
get it
it really is not that complicated
so
when in the weeks and months to come
when they turn their when the right wing
appropriates the merrick garland bad
bear garland need to go
messaging because they're going to trust
me that's what they're doing right now
they're working it up in the [ __ ]
media they're working it up in the cycle
in the loop and the media is going to
play right into their hands here they do
it every [ __ ] time
every [ __ ] time they play into their
hands
they want to make this race not about
hillary clinton because it's really easy
to convince people in the country that
merit garland bad because of hillary
clinton hillary clinton crooked merrick
garland bad got it that's how they're
going to appropriate the message and all
this time all this months that on and on
and on some of the on the left have went
about how merrick garland bad need to
get rid of merrick garland we need to
get rid of him we need to get a new
attorney general guess what they're
about to appropriate their message your
messaging
because you had anti-democracy messaging
is what you had you got to have
pro-democracy messaging all the time
every time and never quit you can't give
in to the [ __ ] anti-democracy [ __ ]
and the anti-democracy messaging no
matter how convenient it may be no
matter how convenient it may be to write
a tweet or make a video about the
january 6 select committee are the only
[ __ ] party that is willing to hold
criminals accountable in this [ __ ]
country who want to tear down our
goddamn democracy they tried to commit a
coup and they're still doing it
and you're gonna tear down the people
that are trying to stop it and have the
only [ __ ] power to stop it now
they're going to appropriate your
message
that's what the fascists are gonna do
now you can choose whether they're
successful or not
so have a pro-democracy message do not
bang up our our democracy by by [ __ ]
on our institutions that's what they
want us to do
they want to divide us they want to pull
wedges in between us
no matter what it is last week it was
medicare for all we talked about it for
two [ __ ] old days
they want wedges between us because they
know if they break up pro-democracy
believers in this country and they can
get people to believe that maybe
democracy isn't what
they want fascist win
do you want fascism do you want
breakfast snarks
it won't be fun
they'll tell you what the [ __ ] to do and
when the [ __ ] to do it
all right
i appreciate you joining me today
remember
remember stay [ __ ] pissed and go
[ __ ] vote keep your pro-democracy
message keep that strategic outrage
and everything you do and everywhere you
go
it is super important that we continue
the pro-democracy message do not let
them do not give them a chance to
appropriate an anti-democracy message
from the left or or the middle anywhere
in between we have to stay together on
this
no matter if we disagree on minimum wage
or student debt whatever the [ __ ] it is
we have to stay together on democracy
that is the most important thing in 2022
and 2024 because here's what we're going
to say 2022 is the most important
election and then we're going to say
2024 is the most important election
because fascists don't give up they're
not going to give up
and while they have the reigns of power
and they have the [ __ ] amplification
straight into americans brains they're
going to continue
and they're going to continue to
propagate russian propaganda and putin's
agenda which is to destroy democracy all
around the world
so stay pissed go [ __ ] vote
have strategic outrage because the only
party in this country that is gonna
deliver
us democracy is democrats at this point
we have no other choice if you're
pro-democracy and you want democracy
well that's your choice because
republicans want to destroy democracy
they want to destroy everything in their
path all of it
stay tuned tomorrow noon eastern 11
central live right here
right here on youtube twitter twitch
we'll see you tomorrow same time same
place surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking